اعلن حزب الله اللبناني تنفيذه ثلاث
عمليات ضد تجمعات للجنود الاسرائيليين
وقال الحزب انه قصف بصاروخي بركان محيط
موقعي السماق ورمسه في مزارع شبعه المحتله
كما قصف محيط قاعده خربه ماعز وتجمع
اسرائيليا في جبل نذر وافاد مراسل الجزيره
ان المقاتلات الاسرائيليه شنت اكثر من 16
غاره على جنوب لبنان فقد استهدف الطائرات
محيطه بلده راميا وجبل بلاط باثنتي عش
غاره كما شنت الطائرات الاسرائيليه اربع
غارات على محيط بلدات العديسي وكفره وعيون
وتعرض محيط بلدات ميس الجبل وحبيب وبليد
والخيام
والعديسات المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
بان القبه الح دي اعترضت مسيره من لبنان
اخترقت المجال الجوي الاسرائيلي فوق البحر
وقال المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي ان
الطائرات الحربيه اغارت على مواقع اطلاق
قذائف ومبان عسكريه لحزب الله في منطقه
قريه راميه جنوبيه لبنان كما اكد استهداف
الجيش الاسرائيلي لمواقع استطلاع وبنى
تحتيه لحزب الله في قريتي حوله وكفر
كلا الى شبكه مرا سينا من الجليل الاعلى
شمال اسرائيل جيفار البديري ومن قل السقي
جنوب لبنان ايهاب العقدي جيفارا هل هناك
اشارات على الارض عن امكانيه توسع
المواجهه كما يعلن قاده سياسيون وعسكريون
اسرائيليون على الاقل من التصريحات
السياسيه هذا ما يشي بامكانيه توسيع نطاق
الحرب قبل قليل ايه صدر عن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جالنت الذي كان يتواجد هنا
عند الجبهه الشماليه قال بانه يجب الوصول
الى امكانيه عوده سكان الشمال بامان الى
منازلهم ولكن اذا لم يتم ذلك بطرق التسويه
فان ذلك معناه التوجه الى حرب قائلا ايضا
بان حزب الله خسر الحرب التكتيكيه
العمليات حسب وصفه وانه يتم ضرب
مواقع حزب الله على طول خط الحدود مع
اسرائيل ولكن ايضا في ذات الوقت هو يقول
لا نريد الحرب ولكن ان وصلنا الى هذا
المفترق اي طريق الحرب فوصف العمليه بانها
ستكون كالسكين اي بقوه كبيره وانه يفهم
انه طالما هناك حرب في الجنوب اي في قطاع
غزه فان هذه الجبهه اي الجبهه الشماليه
ستبقى مشتعله ليس بالجديد كل حديث وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي هو يعني تكرار لكل
التصريحات السياسيه والعسكريه التي يدلي
بها المسؤولون العسكريون منذ العاشر منذ
الثامن من اكتوبر عندما دخل حزب الله على
خط المواجه ولكن على الارض ما نراه ان على
سبيل المثال قوه الردع الاسرائيليه
متواصله بمعنى انه خلال هذا اليوم كان قصف
بالطائرات بالقصف المدفعي ب قذائف الهاون
لاكثر من موقع وعلى طول خط الشريط الحدودي
وفي ذات الوقت كان هناك
ردود من قبل حزب الله والمقاومه في داخل
الجنوب اللبناني وصافرات الانذار دوت
اليوم فقط لمره واحده في منطقه عرب
العرامشه نتيجه صاروخ مضاد للدروع الامر
الذي كان ايضا مربكا شيء اخير فقط جلال هو
المسيره التي التي اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه تمكن من اسقاطها كانت قريبه من عكا اي
صارت كل هذه المسافه على طول الحدود
البحريه واجتازت الحدود و وفق بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيلي ان هذه المسيره كانت
متجهه الى خليج حيفا في اسرائيل لا يوجد
تخوف من امكانيه اطلاق المسيرات اجاه حيفا
لانه لم يتم بعد الرد الفعلي حسب ما يراه
يراهن هنا بان على اغتيال صالح العاروري
وعدد اخر من كبار قاده حزب الله اللبناني
ولكن لا ان يتم المس بالمدنيين ك المصافي
البترول وايضا اصابه عدد اكبر من المدنيين
في حيفا ومناطق اخرى في الشمال طيب ايهاب
قبل ان اتابع معك اشير الى الاخبار
العاجله التي ترد من كتائب القسام عن
التطورات في داخل غزه تقول كتائب القسام
قنصن جنديا صهيونيا ببندقيه الغول القسميه
شمال شرق مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه ايهاب
كيف يتابع حزب الله تصعيد لهجه القاده
الاسرائيليين حول
امكانيه تصعيد المواجهه بين حزب الله
واسرائيل في الايام
المقبله حزب الله يرى بانه لا يمكن
لاسرائيل ان تقوم باي تصعيد عسكري بسبب
قدرات ما وصفها رئيس كتله البرلمان في حزب
الله رئيس كتله البرلمان التابعه للحزب
بان قدرات المقاومه كبيره وفقا للتعبير
الذي استخدمه طبعا هذا الامر يؤشر الى
امرين الى ان حزب الله يعتبر بان لديه
مكام من قوه كبيره لم يستخدمها بعد في هذه
المواجهه واسرائيل تدرك هذا الامر باعتبار
ان كل المواجهات القائمه منذ الثامن من
اكتوبر تقع في منطقه الشريط الحدودي في
جنوب لبنان وان حزب الله يتحرك في تلك
المنطقه فقط ويقوم بتسديد نيرانه باتجاه
المواقع الاسرائيليه او في العمق
الاسرائيلي كما فعل مرات عده ردا على
التصعيد الاسرائيلي وحزب الله يعتبر انه
اذا صعدت اسرائيل في حربها يمكنه ايضا
التصعيد في المقابل اذ ان حزب الله يمتلك
قدرات صاروخيه هائله ولديه ايضا مسيرات لم
يستخدمها ولم يزج في المعركه كامل قواته
في منطقه جنوب لبنان وبالتالي يعتبر حزب
الله بان ما يقوم به هو عمليه اشغال
استراتيجي للقوات
الاسرائيليه لمنع اندفاعها في منطقه غزه
ولديه ايضا اهداف تكتيكيه يريد من خلالها
تحقيق بعض الاهداف العسكريه من خلال تهشيم
الواجهه الاماميه للمواقع الاسرائيليه حزب
الله هذا اليوم اعلن عن مهاجمه ثلاثه
مواقع لكن كان هذا اليوم يحمل الكثير من
التصعيد الاسرائيلي لجهه استخدام الطائرات
الحربيه وتكثيف الغارات 12 غاره على منطقه
في القطاع الغربي وهذه هي منطقه عمليا
مفتوحه منطقه غابات وجبال ووديان قصفتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه باث صاروخ
في هذه الغارات المختلفه وايضا قامت
بمهاجمه منطقه منطقه تقع بين يار ومارون
الراس وكذلك قامت بمهاجمه منطقه العديسي
واحدى المناطق القريبه من بلده كفركلا
التي تقع بين العديسي وكفره كل هذه
المناطق لازالت في ضمن المناطق التي سبق
وانا غارت عليها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وقصفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
عده
مرات حزب الله كان لافتا في هذا اليوم
استخدامه صواريخ التي تحمل رؤوسا متفجره
شديده الانفجار استخدمها في موقع عين من
المواقع الثلاثه التي هاجمها وقال انه حقق
اصابات في
صفوف الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين كانوا
يتمركزون في هذه المواقع او في التجمعات
القريبه منها المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كانت
اليوم ايضا تقوم بقصف مركز على منطقه رشيه
الفخار هي المنطقه القريبه من كفرشوبا حيث
وقعت العمليات وايضا في كفركلا وميس جبل
وبليد وغيرها من المناطق في جنوب لبنان
شكرا شكرا لكما ايهاب في قبل السقي جنوب
لبنان وجيفارا في الجليل الاعلى شمال
اسرائيل